hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and with on this
stream you all get to have a glimpse
inside my day as a front-end developer
at a small University so I do my best to
narrate as I work and I take some time
to do a question and answer session so
usually we do Pomodoro sessions so
25-minute sessions of code take a five
minute break for Question and Answer go
back and forth like that until the end
of the stream and then I answer all the
questions that are left over sometimes
that takes a while sometimes it doesn't
but today we're going to continue what
we have started yesterday which is doing
some styling to our react projects using
the latest version of material UI so
material UI is a framework for a
framework of react components that fit
with the material design style so if
you're familiar with pretty much any of
the apps that Google has come out with
with the exception of maybe a few of the
older ones then you've seen a material
design style let's see I want to start
out first with a pull request so I
received a pull request just a few
minutes ago or maybe 10 10 minutes ago
or so from Sebastian so I thought it
might be cool to start with that pull
request so I'll just go through how I
normally review pool requests usually in
the morning I come in and review any
pull requests so I don't know that I've
actually gone over that process on the
stream so I haven't even looked at this
pull request yet I don't know I don't
know what's in it or how big it is or
anything so this will be exactly my
normal routine when when I see that
there's a pull request so let's go oops
let me type let me give you the n drop
URL so if you want to see the site as
we're working on it and be able to see
it in your browser and use your own dev
tools check out that link that I just
put in a live chat
I'm a paste it in there a little bit
later on for for anyone who's joining us
later so remind me if if remind me a
little bit later on to paste it again if
I forget and failed to complete total
fennekin okay so it didn't work what's
going on here oh okay you know what I
changed the let me paste a different in
I didn't realize I changed the local
host so I need to do it again so I
restarted my installed the latest Mac OS
update and restarted and when I did oh
my all my local servers that I had
running shut down so when I went to run
this again it ran it by default on
localhost 3000 instead of 2001 so that's
where the problem came in so I'm
restarting it now with the correct port
and this link should not work
okay good it looks like it's getting a
lot of status 200 okay is here and the
console my other screen so so that's
working let's go to I don't know why
it's not pulling in any data so we'll
take care of that soon but for right now
I want to go over pull requests so first
I'll go to github let me make this a bit
bigger and increase the font size so you
all can see what's going on so usually I
come in here and I don't know why I'm
not sure why I didn't get a notification
about that usually I have a notification
up here so that's that's weird does I
didn't get the email I guess I could
double-check yeah I did get the email
about it so for whatever reason I didn't
get a notification this time but
normally it will notify you if someone
submits a pull request to your
repository but we'll just go in oh is
this bullets in
I might have to check out area it's down
here so good in this bulletin react and
I just got a slack message from one of
my co-workers I stopped at the grocery
store on my lunch break and picked up a
bunch of cinnamon rolls and she said she
just heated one up in the microwave and
it's amazing now I'm gonna be thinking
about that during the whole stream all
right so let's go to pull requests and
here's pull request number three from
Sebastian and let's check it out I love
that REE factorization
alright so usually I just kind of go
through what was said it looks like this
would be a small pull request only one
file change so when I go through
whatever the person who submitted the
request says then I check out the files
just in general it's easier to merge in
a smaller pull request
I appreciate pool requests of all sizes
but occasionally if I get a really big
pull request if I like 75% of it you
know it's awesome but there's 25% that
I'm not sure about sometimes like I
don't really want to pull the entire
thing in so if it was broken up into
smaller requests I could just pull in
what I need so keep that in mind I when
you're submitting to really any
repositories is I think you have a
better shot at getting your pull request
merged if it's smaller and more focused
because it's less likely to cause merge
conflicts and you know take the the
repository maintainer a really long time
to go through ok so this is in the post
preview and let's see what's changed
it's it's just a refactor so it should
still have the same functionality looks
like
it looks like it's just cleaned
everything up and made it and they did a
bit smaller here so that looks good
actually this is straightforward enough
that I could just merge it right here
but since we're kind of demonstrating
this I'd like to show you how I would go
about testing it so let's go go back to
the terminal and make this a bit bigger
so on a very small pull request like
this where I could very clearly see all
the lines of code I would probably just
merge it right there in github because I
mean it's just so obvious what that code
does but if it's bigger and I really
want to test it out first then I'll go
into my my project so let's see if I
need and Xcode whenever you install an
Xcode update it always messes things up
you have not agreed you must agree to
both hit the enter key
alright agree
all right awesome okay so if anybody
ever read that whole thing I have never
read it that's not even in English I
guess it's not really that long right
it's anyway all right so I'm just
checking the status to make sure we
don't have anything that's uncommitted
that on this branch so we don't and then
now I'm gonna go get fetch origin and
[Applause]
the origin pool and then I'm gonna put
the number of the pool request which in
this case is three and then now I'm
going to name this last part after the
colon is what I'll name the branch so
I'm just gonna say s refactor I'm just
saying s refactor because it's Sebastian
and so far there's only one person whose
name starts with s this submitted pool
request if I had more people I would
probably come up with something better
now I got to do this again since I
restarted all right so let's on my other
screen I'm gonna get my my key let's see
so I don't know this offhand I have it
saved in LastPass
okay let's put that in there and then
I'm gonna do SSH ad and that way it
won't keep asking me for it so if you
ever if you have this happen and you
have to keep putting in your your
passphrase just do run SSH ad and then
put your passphrase in and it'll stay in
there for me it stays in there until I
restart I'm not there's probably some
way to make it stay in there all the
time but maybe it's better if you don't
have to stay in there all the time just
in case somebody gets into your computer
okay so now let's go with I guess it
already works so now we'll go get
checkout yes refactor okay so now we
have that pull request number three
locally on our machine and we can test
it out now at this point you'd want to
remember if any packages have been added
then you'd want to update so you just
run yarn or you know or if you're using
NPM you could do that but we don't have
any new packages added so now we're just
going to check it out see see what it
looks like
since this didn't add any new features
it should be fine basically what I'm
looking for
let's see why this is not loading
that work my sweet it's gonna be code
make sure I save
that's interesting I should be working
let's go to need that oh this is where
it's at you know just make sure the
sights okay so the site is is up let's
go let's go to the admin panel and see
what's going on all right so we have
graph QL I did go back to the older
version oops
and I just remembered I forgot to set my
timer so I'm just gonna keep an eye on
this probably once once we get close to
3 o'clock I'll take a five-minute break
and we'll do some question-and-answer
stuff so if you're asking questions
right now I'm not I'm gonna get to it
probably in about 10 to 15 minutes I'll
check the live chat and get to the
questions ok oh ok so Blake says it's it
is working on end grukk ok let me try
that out then wow it is ok so I'm not
sure what the problem is locally okay so
for now I'm just gonna look here just to
test it out and then we'll worry about
whatever is going on locally in a minute
so I'm just going to go in and click we
only have a few views available
basically I'm just when I test out at
this point it's really simple we don't
have any testing setup so when I want to
test it out I go through and just check
you know the views and see if we're
getting errors and
so we are we are getting some errors but
I doubt that this is related to the the
pool request we can double check by
going back to master and see if it's
still there okay let's see see if we get
this error everywhere this is actually
we went that wasn't the right one that
was still the local okay so something's
wrong with my local host and then this
okay great
so this works without any errors here
and grout so so that's cool now at this
point we could merge from the command
line and if I would do that normally I
would merge in the master branch into
this pull request branch first test it
out again and then merge everything in
the master but I think let's let's check
and see and github if we can merge this
without any without any conflicts okay
so no conflicts so what I'm gonna do is
just merge right here because it's it's
easier to just press that big green
button so like I said I would only do
this on a very small pool requests where
you can see what's changed and it's very
it's obvious otherwise would definitely
test and merge from the command line and
let's confirm that all right also
so
I know Sebastian is watching right now
but I still like to say thank you to
everyone that submits a pull request so
thanks Sebastian and also yeah I'm okay
with this so Sebastian is asking if I'm
okay with it and is to start refactoring
the other components yeah I think this
is that's awesome let's go it was
let me check again post preview that was
it yes in the post preview it looks
great
oops
I didn't actually pull it down haha it's
gonna look even better so let's go get
check out the master get pull to bring
in those changes alright so now we have
that locally now let's check out those
preview ok here's a perspi oh actually
no it was the same thing because we
weren't on the master branch
nevermind I don't know what I was
thinking okay so anyway so Sebastian
that looks great if you want to refactor
some of the other components then that
would be awesome too yeah so
yeah let's do take another like five or
six minutes to do some some more styling
and then we'll do a question and answer
okay let me let's go back here actually
first what we should do is get this
working I could just run off the end
Rock one I guess so I'm gonna give it
maybe like two minutes to try to figure
this out if we can't I'll just do
everything off the end rock but I would
like to see why because yesterday this
was working fine so what are we getting
here
okay
see if we're getting okay
syntax error
mmm
check
okay
I think I'm probably not gonna mess with
this during the stream I'm just going to
do one last thing and that is restart
the server because sometimes that just
works so it's worth a shot I don't
really think it'll work in this case but
it only takes a few seconds all right
hey and it works ha ha I can't believe
it all right let's just read this way
twice all right get out of here let me
pull the one that works over so for some
reason it just didn't work in that tab I
don't know what's going on come on going
in it it won't come up there all right
are you serious
so I can get I can get local hose to
work in other tabs but I can't get it to
work here that's insane
that's so crazy I mean watch this
what what would cause that that it will
work here and not here
all right well this is not a debug
Chrome stream so I'm not gonna mess with
it there we go so I did a hard refresh
and it worked so I'm I don't know what
whatever it works let's just keep going
oh there we go
Blake and put in the live chat cache and
I didn't see it yet so yeah honestly
this those two things probably solve
more problems restarting the server and
clearing the cache oh wow I'm just glad
it works okay so now now let's take a
five-minute break and do questions since
I just took up the last five minutes
just getting that to work so I'm gonna
bring over my timer and we're gonna do a
five minute break I'm gonna go through
the latch and then we'll do another
twenty five minutes of well we're legit
gonna do some some styling I have now
haven't really done much so far but I
think it was worthwhile to go through
the pull request process so I mean if
you've never hosted your own repository
where people were so many pull requests
then you may you may not have gone
through that before okay
okay cool so Sebastian says in regard to
the pull request as I read something
about the previous pull request he had
issues with the new JavaScript syntax or
something I wanted to test with just a
file if everything's okay I'll do more
okay awesome you know did something
weird with an on click hand earlier I
just use the link the read more button
okay so Sebastian is interested to see
about what happens with the read more
button yeah definitely works so yeah I
mean if we're using react router then I
think link is the way to go with that so
it's good of that post detail was that
the one now was it post preview that was
it yeah so link I would think we would
want to use link you know for every
navigation so I don't have the the
previous version to compare it to right
now but that's that's what I would have
done also in regard to that via the new
JavaScript stuff so we do have because
of the way we're using standard Jas
sometimes when we have trying to find an
example of functions okay so alright so
like this we have render post so you get
an error saying render post wasn't
defined so harsh it when he submitted
his full request number two did this
right he defined them here in the
constructor function but what I've been
doing is instead not defining it in the
constructor function so I'll just give
an example now so we're gonna take this
out and instead we're going to use an
arrow function here
that will handle the binding of this and
then to handle the standard Jas
complaining about it or whatever I mean
es lense being used under the hood for
that so I don't know exactly what it is
that's giving the error message about it
we're gonna go into our package JSON and
then down here under our Global's I'm
just I've been putting everything in
Global's you can also do a similar thing
right at the top of the file but it's
just easy to put everything right here
then you can see right at a glance all
the stuff so you have to add a little
bit either way you either have to put
something in the component or you have
to put something in here I kind of
prefer to just put one line here if it
got really huge we could probably take
this out put it in another file if we
wanted to but our package JSON is not
very big at all so this works and then
we save ourselves what was it like four
lines in here inside the component so in
here I would put render post and we'll
say make sure you say both of those and
let's go I'm just gonna run the Lintz so
we can see we shouldn't get an error yep
see it ran through everything we didn't
get the error
but now I'm not it's not loading again
that's gonna be annoying okay I should
have the cash off actually let's double
check that in the settings
[Music]
see where there should be an option to
disable caching when dev tools is open
yep disable cache so that's on so I'm
not sure what's going on with that we
may just have to do a couple of hard
refreshes okay hopefully that cleared up
the whole issue with the air is coming
from senator Chaz let's see kazeem sorry
if I'm mispronouncing name it's qaz I am
so I'm going to say Kazim says hi from
Kosovo hey how's it going thanks for
watching and joining in the live chat
and my five minutes is up so I didn't
get through everything this in a live
chat right now but I will come back to
where I left off and after the next
Pomodoro session we'll do some more
questions
okay
so let's go
you know what let's add in let's make
this actually you know drop down with
some options and we'll add in a few
other of the icons that we need here and
I kind of I like to work my way like
from the top down so we'll get this app
bar you know kind of how we want it and
also actually I think we'll go with the
newer style that we've been doing on the
last project the last couple of projects
where you have the white with the gold
underneath so my boss really likes that
looks clean so let's do that so we'll
change up some of the styles here add
some icons add a drop down and then
we'll throw in probably a logo here in
the sidebar and yeah and then we'll see
how long that takes you know we might
not even get all that done but if it if
we can get all that done then maybe
we'll work on more on this sidebar ok so
let's go into our our theme right so
yesterday we set up a material UI theme
and I believe that was in our layout yes
so in our layout we actually have so
we've brought in part of the theme here
so see how we want to do this
I don't know that I I obviously don't
want to make our primary color white so
what I'll do then is override our
primary color just for that that app bar
so let's for app bar
let's go with
background-color and we'll use oops what
is white FFF yeah it's amazing how light
you use the thing so many times and you
know occasionally you're just you're
just not sure about it okay all right so
that will give us our white so if you're
falling along with an grok you'll see
that the whites right there I have a
second window of this open on my other
screen so I won't have to flip back and
forth quite as much so we have that and
now we want to do a bottom border so
border
so you want to do Solid 3 pixels I think
we were doing three pixels for that
bottom border we can double check at
some point but I think three will work
and we want our color to be let me I
can't remember it offhand we'll have to
grab it from an existing project so I'm
opening up our resource center project
on the other screen just so that I can
grab this this color and it was it was
three pixels so that's good
be consistent there okay so we should
see
oops I forgot my a comma
okay cool so let's see so right now you
can see we have white with our gold
underneath okay so we're going to want
to change our color of our icons and
let's see
let's see if we can just put a color
property on the app bar
it might work might not be specific
enough but if it works and that'll be
great color and so let's do the CL that
works
whoops did I forget a comma again oh man
I've been forgetting commas frequently
lately alright great so that that wall
that at least works for this so we still
need that icon to have the color but
that's good that it worked here and
while we're at it I think I want to
change I definitely want this to be a
smaller font weight and perhaps just a
little bit bigger so let's change that
let's go ahead we can leave all those
really small changes for another time
let's get this what did we say that
those feet with that icon was called was
it more vert I think that's what it was
let's get that more vert icon with the
right color there so I don't think we
have anything for an icon in here let's
see where we're actually putting that
icon in I don't remember plotting
anything okay that's interesting color
contrast
I wonder actually I kind of want to look
up what what it does there with color
contrast so let's check the material
design documentation or outside material
UI so we are using the version 1 and
let's go to icons let me make this a bit
bigger for everyone okay
icons it's just not there then we get
icon somewhere there we go icons
what was that icon button
now let's see what they have here
let's try let's check out the button
component then since we're actually
using an icon button component it may be
here under buttons icon button here we
are okay so this icon button this button
color
okay so color contrast alright let's see
our API is so color color is using the
theme palette when that makes sense
oh okay so it's so somewhere in the
theme we define what the contrast color
is and then it's going to use that
okay so if we reset this to primary it
should pull that green color which is
what we want so let's do that then
so I mean we definitely could have just
overrode this dial and it would have
been a lot faster but I mean just I
think it's nice to work within you know
the way that the people who design
material you I you know set that out to
work it'll be a lot more consistent that
way later on if we decided to change our
primary color this would automatically
change the correspond to it which is
kind of nice probably not going to
change it but it's nice to have it all
linked up like that so you can see now
we have our icon and let's see
so now let's I'd really like to add the
drop down I don't think I've used the
drop down yet for material you I and any
of our projects so this will be cool
it'll be the first time to implement
this on the stream so let's go to back
to our documentation and let me see I
forgot to reset my timer so I'm just
gonna have to look again
so we started this Pomodoro session
around 3:00 so around 325 I just have to
keep an eye on it okay so where's I just
have to figure out what it's called here
and may not be called a drop-down
maybe menu concealer whoops
actually want the demo first so we can
see it and you yeah that's what I want
okay so it's I'm just calling it a
drop-down but it's it's really a menu so
there we go this is we won't need all
these options but that's kind of what
I'm going for when you click on this
then we give it so let's just go with
the simple example and so we're going to
need to grab import this and let's see
menu item to me okay we are importing
that as well great so let's do that in
our in our layout because this is where
we have that app bar so at the top let's
pull in that menu oops oh man let me
move this over
I'm accidentally clicking my mini-map
over here that's what sent me down there
okay so let's do that and now right
below we put it right here below the
icon button oops or this icon button
that way we'll keep them together I'm
gonna be easier to tell you know what
which is which here I probably could
break it out into another component you
know this whole thing but for now we'll
leave it in there can always refactor
later on let's see here it is here's a
menu so I'm gonna copy this all in and
we'll have to change it a bit looks like
we're gonna have to copy in this as well
okay so here's a menu
okay let's pull this in
[Music]
yes
saving needs need this button
need our button to have these as well
it's the icon button it's gonna have a
lot here so let's bring these down just
to help us read it alright let's see if
that's if that will work
oops
haha and these aren't defined so let's
go ahead and put these in our
package.json so what did we have is not
the fun and handle click and the request
closed now states should definitely be
States at work we have it in our package
JSON right yeah we have it in there mmm
that's weird and just handle click
whoops
there we go and it was the other one
handle requests close all right
let's save that see if we get
and that's uh
what'd I miss oh oh actually you know
what yeah that doesn't make sense
because we weren't linting there that
was just a normal air and it's an
Oakland maybe I did I paste this in the
wrong spot
let me see
yep all right thanks Sebastian it's I
based into the wrong place
what was I thinking
yeah be kidding me
Wow all right so we already have state
so let's bring in shoot we're gonna have
to change that so we don't want that to
be open let's go open open menu and
we'll change it down here to open menu
and select all this there we go
open menu all right there we go
now let's bring this in
let's see if we have okay doesn't look
like we're repeating anything and then
we also need to do within here I'm going
to make sure we say open menu okay all
right I think that should work now we
would have had to have had that added
this the package.json at some point
anyway so hey look at that it works
awesome okay cool
so that wasn't too bad to to implement
if I could just photo just pasted it
into the right spot it would have been
even easier all right awesome so that
works we're not going to want all of
these we're gonna keep logout and then
actually let me I don't remember what
other options should be there let me
check the time so I don't pass up the
next okay so maybe in about seven
minutes or so we'll do our next question
and answer session so if you got any
questions in the live chat and I haven't
responded I'm not ignoring you I would
definitely get to it in the question
answer session or at the end of the
stream let's see I'm just
double-checking here my other screen
what I want in that menu what
actually let me bring this over because
I don't think I've shown how the login
works so this is currently how the login
works for the live version of the
bulletin so if your if the login data is
not saved in local storage it shows this
screen so I can type and so I type in my
email JY by Franciscan edu if I were to
put in an email address that wasn't at
Franciscan ddu it wouldn't let it go
through so even if you did something
with dev tools and let it go through it
still wouldn't it wouldn't work so it
checks on the client side and the server
side so when I submit this I get a link
sent to me so whoops that's not it
chuna pull the link over on the screen
there it is okay so I get this link and
second display images alright so this
link comes in if I click it then I'm
signed in to the bulletin and then Oh
Acts
I guess I'd only had logout as the
option right now all right well so I
guess we can take out the other options
for now and that lengthy you get is a
it's a single-use link so once it's used
once then you won't be able to log in
again if you try to use it again you'll
get an error message so that's the
current login system which hopefully
we're going to be changing that soon
although it does work well as long as
some users do clear out their local
storage often so it doesn't work well
for them but for people who don't do
that
it makes it really easy because you can
basically you stay logged in for a year
as long as you're not clearing anything
out
okay
let me but I am to do this just so we
can see my stuff again alright so let me
take out right now our other menu items
depending on how much time we have and
what we want to do with this I would
like to add in some menu items like
profile or my account to allow users to
customize their experience a little bit
but since we're not we don't have
anything like that right now just going
to keep things clean in here and take
them out it seems silly to have a menu
like that for one item but it was it was
kind of always intended to have more
just haven't haven't really had time to
come back to this project since it wants
last year
okay so let's add in let me check the
current version of this so we want to
add a printer icon and then kind of a
grid icon and a search search icon
so let's go I wonder we'll probably have
to go to our icons to get the name so
there we go alright so if you if you
want material design style icons this is
definitely the place to go material do
slash icons you get all these icons here
and you can get them in several
different formats right now we have
already imported these icons so we can
use them in our project but if I hadn't
imported them I you like to grab the the
SVG code for them and just put it in
line so let's look for the print icon
first alright so here we have print and
we can see you know we could grab the
SVG the ping or we could pull it in as
an icon font we can pull it in we can
use different colors here we're going to
change the color of that green that
we've been using so that doesn't really
matter you know if we were to grab the
SVG doesn't matter by
I just mean you know we can download the
SVG
and then open it up copy and paste the
code right there in line into our
project but for now I just wanted to
make sure of the name so we should be
able to just use print icon so let's
grab our icon button and I'm gonna paste
it and paste it in here I'm hoping that
this goes to the left of our current
that's more vert icon button we'll see
not sure let's see for now let's get rid
of these this will probably end up
having will may end up putting a link
component either inside the button or
wrapping the button in the link
component but for now we just want it to
get we want it to show up so assuming we
can just do prints since we already have
color primary it should be the right
color I'm gonna save that and let's
check it out for an icon is not defined
well I don't think we imported it up
here revert icon actually can we there's
got to be a better way to do this than
importing them all these icons
separately right oh well when maybe
we'll figure that out at some point but
you would think that you could just do
something like this right and import
from icons
all right so let's try it now we're
actually importing that first for an
icon great alright awesome and that
worked just like we wanted it to you
know the print icon there as well so
it's time to do another five-minute
question answer and we can have all our
icons there probably doesn't need quite
so much space in between but that's
something you know that's a little thing
that we can adjust later on sometimes if
you try to adjust at least for me in my
experience if I try to adjust those
little things early on they want to get
more things on the page I end up wanting
to adjust them again and it's better if
I just hold off until I get like a
clearer picture of the hole more things
on the page then I then I end up
adjusting once instead of multiple times
throughout okay so let me go to my live
chat and I'm gonna scroll up to the
point where I left off and get through
as much as I can in five minutes at the
time yeah I think we'll go with three
Pomodoro sessions so I know yesterday we
didn't do quite as much coding as we
normally do so we'll make up for it
today by putting in an extra session and
so we'll have a five-minute question
answer now another 25 minutes of code
and then afterwards we'll have a long
question answer session where I can get
to everything that's left over after
these five minutes so let me bring out
my timer I don't know where I put it
and I got minimize that I did all right
here we go okay
okay so James asks how do I have to be
are ok how skilled do I have to be to
join these live streams actually it
doesn't it really depends on kind of
what you want so we we go over some some
things that are like a whole different
range of skills so sometimes we go over
things that are more advanced sometimes
we do things that that aren't really
that advanced so depending on what we're
working on for a particular stream it
may be more useful to you if you know if
you're at a lower skill level so it
generally it's I like to have a mix of
different skill levels watching and in
the live chat and then that way the
people who you know really skilled can
help out can help me out and can help
the other people in the live chat out
with any issues that they're having and
help to explain and I try to do my best
to explain as them as I'm going along so
if I'm not explaining well feel free to
ask any questions so I may not look at
the live chat during the code session so
I at at one point where you're streaming
I tried to go through the live chat all
the time and it ended up that we just we
didn't get a lot of code done at all so
that's why I've kind of separated them
out but I will get to your questions
eventually but I mean if you it kind of
depends on if you want if you want like
a straight tutorial that really gets to
the point this is probably not the best
place for that because you know we're
always working on something different
and it's it's not really methodical and
how we teach things so it's more just to
show like here's what my normal day is
as a front-end developer but I do try
try to do my best to explain things so
you could get something out of it see
Sebastian says with react 16 you can use
class instead of class name right okay
and Melissa says yes that's cool I
hadn't I didn't realize you could do
that
I actually just read through some react
16 stuff before the stream today it
looks like there's a lot that changed
behind the scenes that make it faster
and neck and smaller so that's pretty
awesome
okay James says can you do a beginning
code that lined up the first project and
free code camp yeah so yeah that one was
the one so I started to do that one on
my own channel so if you come in just in
the free code camp channel it's I've
already done a few streams at that point
so you don't see you like the startup so
check out I think I have linked in the
description of this video the link to my
channel my personal channel so if you
check that out and you go to the project
that is the title of the first video is
building a website as fast as I can
let's it ended up not being that fast
but initially because of the deadline it
was going to be really fast but gets on
some leeway there so check that video up
first if it's still not I don't remember
exactly where I started out there but if
it still needs like even more
introduction I'm definitely open to
going back maybe and you know kind of
doing more of an introductory video on
that but yeah check that one out I do
maybe two or three streams on my own
channel and then I switch over to freako
cam
okay John Hanson says had a hard time
getting modal's to work as I would like
and react even with react router looking
forward to reworking modal's and react
16 awesome yeah so John have you been
have you been using a framework like
material UI or trying to do modal's from
scratch because I think something like a
framework it does make it pretty easy
all right me let me mark down where I'm
even off at and we'll do one more
session of coding
all right and I just saw right when I
was working down the time so in us as
hey what are you building a a Niles are
going we are working on a react project
with with graph Pio we're using Apollo
to bring in stuff from graph qo and
we're styling it today with the latest
version of material UI ok alright so all
right let's throw in those next there's
two icons quickly since we know we know
how to do it and it'll work so we just
need to get the names of those icons so
we want a grid not like that layouts see
if it's in layout
actually the me I'm gonna inspect the
the current site that we're redoing and
see if I use the material I con mathira
khan grid button we call it a quilt is
it huh wow it is called view quilt Wow
I would not have guessed that okay so
let's do the quilt and I'm just gonna
I'm not gonna put it in twice now go get
in there so let's do view quilts and
down here
let's figure out this and I'm gonna copy
it twice in here since we know we're
going to do another one and for this one
we want the few quotes and I'll save
that and then finally we want the search
I'm almost positive search is just gonna
be search so let's just try that out
before we look it up search I'll go up
to the top
all right let's check it out awesome so
we have our icons here great cool all
right so let's move on and try to put
the logo up in this corner I think so by
default this is gonna be open so on it
on a large screen let's see it look
pointed okay so we actually don't have
it we're gonna have to change this so
that it's not always open because on a
mobile that just doesn't give us enough
room but so we may be able to display
the logo on mobile I'm okay actually
with not like you know let's say this is
closed we go to a small screen and we
just have something like this of course
we'd want this text to be over here but
I'm okay with not having the logo appear
immediately and instead it appears when
you click this oops
and it looks like we need to change the
color of this as well I've forgotten
about that icon there should be a
hamburger menu icon here but it's it's
white so let's change that right now
before you forget so anyway I think a
logo right here will work let's change
that color though so if we go down our
icon button instead of contrast we want
to give it the color primary which we if
you remember from before we set that
primary color as our green so now yep
there we go so now we have that icon
awesome all right so let's check out
this sidebar component and see if
there's some way to put a logo up here
already built-in if not you know we'll
have to make it work so where's my
documentation I don't think we need
these icons anymore so
see the drawer see what we called that
component yeah okay it is a drawer using
a persistent drawer
awesome
okay so I don't see yeah I don't see any
example with something up here let's
check out the drawer API and see if
there's anything anything that we could
use
okay so let's see anything so let's look
in here and see if we can figure
something out so classes from your
header okay so here's our drawer header
that's where we would want to put it so
far we do have an icon button here we do
want to keep that so let's try to put in
an image into here and need to bring in
I don't think we have a folder yet for
images so for now
I'm going to grab the image address from
another site that Resource Center site
so eventually we'll want to actually
bring in the image but for now this will
let us test it out quickly so there may
see is there an image I don't know if
there's an image component built into
media built into material UI alright I
don't see one so we'll just go with a
regular image alright so this at least
will give us something to work with for
now to see what it looks like
right now hmm
there we go okay so we have the image in
there right now it's way too big again
it's covering up our our icon to close
this so definitely need some work we can
do a little bit of that right here in
dev tools just make this a bit smaller
and let's work on dev tools
see where sidebar is there we go okay so
let's give this see if we could do with
percent so that's a little bit better we
want to give it let's give it a margin
16 pixels it's let's increase it a bit I
want to see I want to see where that
button went to all right interesting so
maybe if we switch the order it may work
out a little better for us with that
button
we could try
let's let's try I'd rather not mess with
this button as much because you know
everything's set from within the mature
UI theme for that so instead let's let's
try to position this in a way that will
allow this button to do this thing
normally what I'm thinking is if we go
and do something like this
well now it's messing up everything I
didn't think about these ones down here
[Music]
all right so that might not be an option
and keep that in mind though but then
we'd have to position things these down
further so for now it's not really an
option let's see if we do
if you can use flex
one simply does for us nothing
yeah let me switch the order then
oops and I did not add my styles on this
so good thing we didn't have too much
going on all right so to shrink it down
okay so this is giving us something a
little bit more like what I wanted at
least this button is visible and it's in
the right spot
I'm guessing what we'll probably want is
for this to be up a little bit further
so we don't have to move the logo down
quite so far yeah under if we
it's gonna check the live chat quickly
as well to see if anyone has any
solution actually image tag before the
button saying okay cool just receive
anyone had any thoughts on this
okay
nice image
let's see I do I want to check before I
start messing with this button too much
I want to check the API for the button
and see what we can do through the API
otherwise we'll just have to override
some stuff which is okay so
okay so we can not but you know I don't
want to override all the buttons so I'm
not going to do it like this we'll just
do it in line on that particular button
so let's try some things out here in dev
tools you check my time okay
yeah we try some things out in dev tools
see what we can do
actually position:absolute might not be
this might not be bad for this we can
just put a margin on the image what do
we do before 16 yeah we definitely need
it to be a bit more than that okay we'll
see Outlook I'm actually not now that I
see this I don't like all the space on
the top but give it a shot for now and
let's see why do we have all this space
anyway that's good
interesting
I really don't like that what do you all
think I'm not I'm not a fan of this does
not look good to me
okay you know what yeah if you're if
you're checking this out through and
Rock you won't see any of this right now
because I'm just doing this in dev tools
yes so that's not I guess the the
alternative is to not potentially if you
don't have to give users the option to
close this currently there is no option
to close this on the the version that's
live right now I'm usually all for
giving users as many options as possible
but in this case it's something that the
users can't do now and I haven't had any
any requests for it so an on mobile it
would open and then you would simply
have to click outside of it to get it to
close so you know you hit the icon for
it to open so how about I'd say for now
let's just take this out or we could
have even commented out just so that we
don't forget that it's there
maybe we'll comment it out and then
we'll come back to it later on if we
have time because I think that's that
falls into the category of something
that would be a nice feature but it's
certainly not a necessary feature and
especially since I've I've never had a
request from a user to be able to do
this I think probably it's it's not
necessarily worth the time to get this
to work right now yeah so let's do that
so I'm gonna do
we do comments and reacts like this yep
there we go
there's not some better way to do
comments and react right am i I don't to
be that missing let's do this we don't
take up quite as much space there we go
alright so as far as I know that's the
only way to do comments and reacts all
right so let's say that we'll probably
want to comma comment out the Chevron
left up top here otherwise it'll
probably tell us somewhere that we've
imported this and we're not using it
no I got it Judy are you really I don't
know what's going on with this okay so
now on our image let's go let's just add
to this to these styles and let's do a
logo styles and we can put with 100%
whoops forget this is an object not
normal CSS with a hundred percent and
let's add some a set of margin I will do
padding all the way around we'll give it
eight pixels see how that looks but I
think eight pixels will look alright we
might want a little bit more maybe on
the top we'll see oops and I forgot my
comma and I forgot to tie it and who our
component down here so let's find our
image
yeah it's gonna pass it up right there
we go let's go to a style and what do
you call that logo sis styles we did
pull that in two styles right
you'll find another spot where you use
that
just as Tyl he equals the only using it
in one place all right well we can see
if it'll work here nope it didn't
and we're using this somewhere right
classes flex okay
this
it's not really
it's easy
classes that
wait a second what am I doing wrong
class name clot that's it thank you
Sebastian class name classes okay
on my other my react native project I'm
doing everything with the style tag so
I'm saying style when I'm bringing in
styles dot whatever that's what I kept
trying to do and I don't have it set up
like that for this okay not bad maybe oh
yeah maybe
didn't give it
you
so do we have if this side bar has a
fixed width which it does all right
let's try this 250
two-fifty
oops let's try 2 34 pixels okay that
works
the accomplice is basically the same
thing so here's so basically what I did
instead of doing with 100% which was not
letting us get our our margins the way
we wanted since this has a fixed width
the sidebars are fixed with the 250
pixels what we wanted was 8 pixels on
each side so we just made the logo 234
pixels which gave us that extra 16 for
each side and then we had 8 pixels on
the top and the bottom and then for
right and left we set it to auto which
splits it equally so that's how we got
our positioning here so now we'll go
back over and change this in the
component so go back up to where we set
our logo styles so you want to 34 pixels
and 8 pixels of Auto
and
okay actually that's we're not getting
our eight pixels on the top and the
bottom will just happen oh oh I didn't I
had switched it to margin let's see if
that makes a difference
yep it does okay great all right not bad
and my timer went off so it's just in
time we got that that done so we have
our whole top portion pretty much done
I'd like to make a few little little
changes here and there really minor
things so next up will be getting the
rest of this sidebar looking like it's
supposed to and then when we want to
building out some of the views okay so
let me actually I want to commit this
now because I I've been forgetting to
commit and later on so I don't want
anybody even wants to maybe work on this
to have you know the older version of
the code so let's check our status see
what's changed okay this looks good
these are the things that we we did
actually changed so let's go get commit
we're gonna add the am flag which means
adds we're gonna add all those files
then we're also going to put in a commit
message at the same time in line with
our command so let's say icons
okay that works and then we're gonna get
push origin master to push that up to
github it's going to do all its most
Auto formatting checks and everything
wait did it do all for money
that was weird
for some reason it wasn't automatically
running that so I'm not sure what's
going on with that so I guess I'll do
another commit
okay
yeah it didn't do the normal lifting all
right so that's all up in the github
repo so everything that we've done is
available now the link to the repo is in
the description so now I'm gonna scroll
back up to where I left off in the live
chat so if you can't stick around for
the live chat thank you so much for
watching I'll be back tomorrow sometime
around 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
but if you can stick around definitely I
hope you can and help out with answering
questions or asking some of your
questions I am gonna try to get through
all the questions I do I have an
appointment at 5:00 so it probably can
I'm probably safe to go at least a half
hour with questions and so we'll see
hopefully I can get through everything
normally not only able to okay
see
James says he just seems to want to
impress someone and not here to help out
what are these projects based upon
anyway I'm not sure is James James might
be talking about me I don't see him
talking about anybody else so anyway
yeah James I don't know so I'm not sure
how much you've seen but it's actually a
probably the opposite I don't know that
I impress that many people with this I
frequently mess up and make mistakes
that's kind of the whole point is for
people to see someone who is employed
full-time as a front-end developer
making a lot of mistakes and trying to
work through it so yeah so if I was out
to impress I would not live stream I
would record and edit out all of my
mistakes usually the most impressive
thing that happens in the stream or the
pool request that you all submit it
makes the projects so much better than I
ever could have made them and the
projects the projects are actually based
upon my work project so I'm currently at
my job and I work on whatever my boss
says I need to work on so that's why we
have a few projects going on at once and
sometimes we switch projects depending
on what's what's needed so that's what
it's based on the styling is based on
the style guide for the University of
that work at so I have I do have quite a
bit of freedom in the tools that I use
but there are some things that I can't
change so one of it being you know we've
set the styles so I kind of have to
stick with that you know I have some
leeway with that but we couldn't just
completely change and go with like an
entirely different philosophy on design
let's see James says do you know skills
enough to explain to people how to
adjust their issues that we have with
coding I never seen a coding channel in
a fashion such as this can you help us
out
I can definitely try to help you out so
if you have any
put them in the live chat and you can
also ask me questions on other social
media things so if you send me something
on Twitter so my Twitter is linked in
the description as well or really
anything i have i've got messages on
linkedin facebook twitter instagram
through email any of those i'll try to
get back to you as soon as i can i can't
always get back right away because i you
know i have a lot going on i have four
kids and my job and I'm taking a Udacity
daño degree course so I can't respond
immediately but I do always try to get
back to everyone eventually with some
help or at least some helpful links as
in regards to whether I have enough
skills to explain to people I don't
really know that's why I say in the live
chat you know anybody who if you can
stick around for the live chat even if
you're an expert and don't have
questions I definitely appreciate your
sticking around and helping to answer
questions because you know in this field
even if I were an expert at something I
can't be an expert at everything so
they're always going to be questions
about things that I don't I've never
used before so when that happens you
know I'm I'm fine with saying hey I
don't really know you know does anybody
else have any input so in terms of my
skills I you know I don't know you all
can can tell me I have I have had some a
lot of positive feedback though that
people say that I have helped out
certainly in regard to someone who's
just starting out I'm pretty confident
in my CSS my HTML skills in terms of
react you know I'm still going through
and learning things I'm much much better
than I was even you know six months ago
so you know this show we're kind of all
learning together and helping each other
out so you know I'll do my best to give
advice when I can but then also let you
all know whenever I'm probably not the
best resource so you know take take what
I say for what it is
let's see okay
okay Paul says in response to James says
he's far ahead not at the beginning
level you can google on material UI and
he's showing us how to style using
material you eye components yeah so this
this particular stream was not
necessarily beginner level so you
probably would have had to have some
knowledge of how react works and maybe a
little bit about material UI so this
particular shame not maybe not really
good for beginners maybe some of the
later on we were just doing some basic
you know positioning stuff with CSS it
would be project three has some stuff
that it's not react based it's more like
just plain HTML and CSS we are dealing
some with some c-sharp templates but I'm
gonna do some things with project three
to make it a lot more beginner friendly
especially for beginners to submit pull
requests so I've had some other stuff
that I had to work on when I'm not
streaming so I haven't been able to get
that ready yet but hopefully I'll be
finished up with with some updates I
need to make to that project one that we
had done and when I'm done with that
maybe it'll free up a little bit more
time for me and I can get that going so
as we go back into project three from
time to time that's probably the best
place for beginners right now okay James
says sorry for beating you up but I'm
wanting to get my point across oh don't
worry about it yeah definitely I any
questions or comments or anything I
definitely welcome even if it's
criticism because I want to make these
streams you know as good as they can be
for you also don't feel bad about you
know any any comments let's see James
says well well think of us let's see he
didn't say that when he first started
making videos about coding okay I'm not
sure what I would he said at that time
or what I said at that time so see okay
Sebastian says you know he will answer
your question when she finishes yeah
yeah so yeah so if I mention from time
to time but if if you come into the
stream in the middle of a session just
just to let you all know I'm not
ignoring the live chat so I do get to
the questions but I have to space it out
otherwise I just can't get coding done
if I'm constantly going back and forth
from questions to code so I've tried
doing it like that and the streams end
up being really long and we don't really
get that much done so we kind of split
out the the question answer session from
that but we still do get to the
questions
see I Paul says it's a series just a
demo of his talent on advanced topics so
thank you for that Paul but I I don't I
kind of gone with what I said before I
don't know that this is a demo of my
talent yeah so that the point is like
and I know I've said this before but for
anybody who's new that's watching I
there are so many great people that are
doing tutorials like free recorded
tutorial videos and they're awesome but
the thing that I thought might be
helpful that I can help with I didn't
really think I could compete with the
people that are already doing great
tutorials but I thought at least I can
help new developers out by showing them
what it's like for me as a full-time
developer and just how many mistakes I
make and how hard it is to work through
because sorry I just realized I left my
fan on so I apologize if the fan was
kind of annoying to anybody I just
turned it off so anyway I am I just
thought it might be helpful for people
to see like when you see the coding
videos that are tutorials it seems like
the people doing it are awesome they
don't make any mistakes right which is
fine for those videos because
you want to get to the point you want to
teach people so you don't want to leave
in all mistakes but I thought it might
be helpful for people to see that you
know even someone who does have a
full-time job as a programmer still
makes those mistakes sometimes really
silly mistakes I mean if you've if
you've watched previous streams you know
sometimes I just make you know
ridiculous mistakes and it takes me
forever to figure it out
so anyway that's that's what I thought I
brought to it so it's not it's not
really me demonstrating my skills or
anything like that if I do something
awesome on the live stream then that's
great that's really cool but I also
think it's really cool when I mess
something up on the live stream and that
can be more helpful than me doing it
right because you know then you'll see
the mistakes that I make and you know
you're kind of ahead of the game you
won't make those same mistakes
because you've already seen me do it and
we've worked through it together I need
to come up with like a really brief way
to say that and just say it at the
beginning of all the shows and maybe put
it in the description because I think I
say that frequently and maybe I'll like
write it out and condense it as much as
I can
let's see
Carlos says that comma issues should be
caught by the linter Yellen set on well
I thought I had it set on commit to lint
but for some reason it wasn't it wasn't
working right so but anyway yeah what I
need to set things up so that it
automatically does it as I'm typing okay
cool set James says I'm on
myfirstproject and free code camp so
awesome James that's great starting out
so yes so if you have any questions
about any of the free code camp stuff
let us know here in the lab chat or like
I said you know on some other form of
social media I'd be happy to help out if
I can
let's see James says can you build a
dating website I would like to learn
about that is that hard hard work yeah
so well like I mentioned before since
I'm doing these streams from work I
really like I need to work on my work
project so I work for University so I'm
not going to be working on a dating
website but it potentially some of the
things that we work on here could be
used for other projects I know some
people have taken some of our previous
projects clone the repo and then change
things to make it work for their use
case so that's possible too you could
definitely build a website like that
with react I don't know in terms of like
the back end in the database we don't
get into databases very much at all on
this stream although we might in the
future
so there's definitely more to it than it
would be in this stream but you know in
terms of all the front end you know you
could definitely learn enough to build
out a front end for something like that
Sebastien says so we were talking about
this sign let this drop down menu and
saying you know right now it really only
has one option and so Sebastian says
it's kind of pointless why not just have
a logout button and you're right
Sebastian so basically there were two
reasons why I made it like this
initially one is I intended to have more
options there and I just never had time
to put them in also I wasn't sure what
the proper button is for logout that's
kind of universally known so one of the
requirements was this had to work for
people who are not really that familiar
with computers so I don't know I mean to
be honest with you now that I think
about it would people really know that
this was a menu so if anyone has any
ideas for an icon that would mean logout
we can go with that but I really would
like to have some other options here if
we could to give users you know some
some customization so we'll see
hopefully for now I'm going to leave it
in just because I hope to put more
options here but if we get closer to the
time when this is going to launch and we
still don't have options then maybe
we'll swap in some icon and we'll just
put a tooltip over it so that people
will know what it what it does let's see
all right James says does anybody have
the heart to help me with advice as a
developer X I mean I think but going to
free code camp is already a great kind
of first step so if you work through the
free code camp stuff and try to
supplement that with maybe YouTube
videos knotti not necessarily these
streams but there's a lot of other great
streams on free code camp and other
YouTube channels so like all of on this
channel like Bo's JavaScript videos are
great great like intro to different
things in JavaScript so when you get to
that part in free code camp check those
videos out also for like CSS stuff dev
tips is a really good YouTube channel
that I've gone to for a lot of more like
design and CSS things for some more
JavaScript stuff and build tools and
things like that learn code Academy is a
great JavaScript or a great YouTube
channel that I've used before and then
so there's a lot of different types of
videos on the free code camp channel too
so if you check out some of the
playlists there's just a huge variety of
content so I'm kind of I'm the only one
that does like the day-to-day live
streaming kind of thing but there's a
lot of other really talented people that
you do great tutorial videos and things
so so definitely check those out if
you're more the type of person that
likes to learn by reading there's a book
series it's you just called you don't
know Jay s and that's actually for
available for free on github so you can
just read it online so check that out
that's that's really good and my only
other advice if you're new is like just
keep working through it you're
definitely gonna have some times I know
I did where it just seems like I'm
working on this problem and I just can't
can't get through it but just don't give
up keep on working and once you finally
get through that problem you're gonna
feel great and you're always gonna look
back at you know where you were at a few
months ago and just realize like
I've come so far and that's pretty
awesome feeling so for me at least it's
definitely worth it you know to just
keep going and keep trying to push
through and and it's great if you have
other people around so like this live
chat is how we form kind of a little
community here so you know if you need
if you need some help or you just need
somebody to say like you know hey keep
going for it you can do it you know it's
kind of cool to have a little community
so it doesn't have to be this community
for the live chat if you have some other
people in your area you can meet with
that's that would be amazing too but if
anyone else has any advice please put it
in the live chat and I'm sure some of
you probably already have I haven't got
to it yet let's see
okay in US if I've ever used UJS and is
it better than react I have never used
UJS but I know some really good
developers I don't mean no personally I
mean like just through Twitter and stuff
so I know some really good developers
who loved UJS and have used both you and
reacts so I don't really know I would
view seems really promising and I think
maybe one day I'd like to try it out I'm
just really trying to get good with
react at this point so I don't want to
branch out right now I mean you know how
it is you can know a little bit about a
lot of things you can specialize and get
really good at one thing so I'm kind of
in specialization mode right now but if
I get to the point where I feel kind of
confident and want to branch out a bit I
think I will definitely try view but
until I try it I don't know that I
really would have a great opinion on
whether it's better than react I mean
I'm happy with reacts so far I really
like it but you know there's also a lot
of people that like view so I'm sure
it's good to see Samson says the hover
menu completely hides the button yeah it
does we could probably work on that if
we do decide to keep the hover menu I
mean it I guess it doesn't really matter
that it hides the button because you you
don't really need to click the button
again but it might not be quite as weird
if we push it down a bit and up we could
probably do that this this loading thing
is bothering me so I'm just refreshing
let's see eric says react jess is the
future I mean that it does definitely
keeps growing so at least for the for
the foreseeable future I don't think
it's going anywhere anytime soon John
Hansen says I'm a from scratch type of
person I used to I'll be all about like
trying to do things from scratch but I
definitely appreciate some boilerplate
now when I got to get a project done
quickly you know that really helps but
it is definitely good to know how to do
everything from scratch and really
understand you know what's what goes
into you know setting things up Eric
asked it has Adam gotten really buggy
for you was thinking about switching
back to visual studio code but want to
stick with Adam actually Adam has gotten
a little bit buggy so on this computer
it's fine but on my laptop it's been
really buggy lately I don't understand
why I have the same plugins on both for
the most part using the same version so
I don't know I haven't really dug into
the problem yet to see what's going on
maybe I just have some outdated plug-in
that I need to get rid of but yeah I'm
not quite ready to switch completely to
Visual Studio code but I have been using
it some so we'll see I'm right now I'm
still with Adam let's see
all right I'm just going to try I think
I'm gonna skip some of the comments to
make sure I can get to all the questions
so look at there's some discussion about
Adam here
see
see Kim says normal HTML style comment
works in and JSX
okay cool okay cool innocence thank you
it is a pretty useful stream awesome
thanks for thanks for saying that I'm
glad I'm glad it's useful to you okay
Sebastian said this there's another live
stream scheduled for free code camp a
live workshop basics of JavaScript and
es6 syntax
I'm not witness is scheduled I'm not
cutting into it right let's try to look
for I didn't get a notification about it
yet so hopefully it's not I'm not taking
up their time
Kiyoshi says what tips would you
recommend a junior developer interested
in getting a job and reacts so I would
say build build things with react I mean
that it sounds straightforward I know
but that's like build things with react
having a github if you're not already on
github get a github profile and put code
in there just get good ideas for
different react projects so just think
about something like an app or something
that you think would be useful and make
it get ideas from your friends and
family and just do it so if you if you
have the time like the free time to be
able to do it that's great if you need
to work and actually make money you know
try to get some clients and make things
and react even make things that don't
necessarily need to be in react but just
do it in react for the practice
you like employers will want to see that
you can actually do the work so they'll
want to look at github they'll want to
see demos of what you can do so that
would be my biggest thing the other
thing would be if you can't network so
either online
and so like on your social media
accounts talk about being a developer
talk about how much you like being a
developer try to comment in a helpful
way to to other developers especially on
Twitter Twitter seems to be pretty big
for you know for developers so because
employers will look at that right if
they see and they're really interested
in you they'll check your social media
stuff so you know if your social media
is full of things entirely unrelated to
development they might think you don't
really care about it or if it's full of
a lot of negative things about how much
you hate you know this or that about
JavaScript or something then they might
think you're too negative of it so just
keep that in mind that anything that you
put online is public your employer would
potentially see so just start kind of
working on building up you know kind of
your online presence as being someone
who is positive and excited about being
a developer and helping other developers
so that's kind of that's my my advice to
you I'm sure there's a lot of other
things that you could do but for me I
know when I've been involved in the
hiring process for developers and I
immediately want to look at their github
repo and look at projects that they've
worked on and check that out
and then if I'm interested I will check
out their social media and I'm more
interested in that than their resume so
I mean I do look at the resume but if
someone has an amazing resume but they
don't include a link to github and I
can't find any of their code anywhere
I'm not really interested
maybe if no one else applies I would
reach out to them but if there are other
people with the less impressive resume
but I actually see their stuff on github
and it's good I'm much more likely to
want to interview that person
various says which Udacity nano degree
are you taking I'm taking the react nano
degree
so I've there there are three projects
for that nano degree I'm done with the
first two I just need to do the last one
which is react native app and then
hopefully if I do the last one and it
works and everything then they don't
have my nano degree so I'm hoping to
have all that done by the end of this
month and when I get done with my my
last project oh I'll show you all in the
livestream if you want maybe during like
one of the question-and-answer sessions
give you a little little preview of it
let's see she says in 2017 what should I
learn to be a full sack developer I am
fluent in front-end design HTML CSS
bootstrap JavaScript what should I learn
to become a full stack developer Vleck
spirit says no js' yeah yeah for sure I
recommend no js' it'll probably be
easier for you to learn node since you
already know javascript then to switch
to a completely different language so it
kind of depends it like really on what
you want to work with but if you don't
have any specific company or technology
you want to work with and I'd go with
node that'll probably the easiest
transition as you should also ask about
the database vole expert recommends
[ __ ] DB is popular with node yeah I've
heard great things about [ __ ] DB there
are some really cool things people were
doing with couch and pouch DB so check
that out
I've seen some some cool demos at
conferences with that it couldn't hurt
to learn a little bit about sequel based
databases because you you're likely to
end up at a company that uses sequel
because it's it's definitely used more
often than no sequel stuff so I try to
be familiar with both
with both types but if you want to
specialize
I said Mongoose does seem to be really
popular with with node various says
don't wait to be an expert to code start
now yeah definitely yeah the only way
you get better is just it's actually
code just work your way through it
okay so blake has a suggestion for the
logout icon let's check it out
serial icons and what was that called
exit exit - okay we'll see what do you
all think
does this icon if you saw this icon
would you think it was a logout icon let
me know like I said we can put a tooltip
over it as well so if users are unsure
what it means we can have it there I
definitely I don't want people to
accidentally log out and now now that I
think about it that was that was another
reason why I did do it like this so I
didn't want users to accidentally log
out so I made it did you had to click
twice to log out because one of the big
selling points of when I presented this
I did some some workshops to teach
people how to use this when it first
launched one of the big things was hey
you don't have to worry about a password
you don't even have to log in very often
you log in once and you're logged in for
a whole year and people like that so I
didn't want it to be easy to log out
because there really would be no reason
for someone to want to log out unless
they were on a public computer and you
know didn't want to stay logged in so
anyway that's another thing to consider
that I just didn't remember from when we
were talking about it before let's see
Sebastian's or Blake says or lock open
let's see what that is open
yeah I'm not so sure to me this wouldn't
I don't know that I think of logout when
I see this but maybe maybe I'm wrong
about that let me know what you all
think Peter says I hate this loading
thing on my screen do something about it
that must have been before I got rid of
it as well yeah I couldn't take the
loading thing either okay okay good
Sebastian said this dream doesn't start
for 50 minutes and it looks like you
said it less than 10 minutes ago all
right so we'll be good we'll be done by
then
oh that's a good idea okay cool so okay
Sebastian said what about a simple
logout button or power settings for
material okay so it looks like we have
some option we'll check out some more
buttons not right now cuz I'm gonna have
to leave in a few minutes but all right
well we'll look at some some more of
these icons and see which one will be
appropriate because blake has a great
idea here is to say possibly after
clicking it have a prompt reading are
you sure you want to log out I like that
I think that that makes more sense than
what I was doing with making users click
twice yeah that makes a lot more sense
so we'll just have a little dialog come
up that says that so anyway so yeah I
really like that idea and yeah so we'll
do that this is actually starting to
look look not bad here got some row I
con I mean they don't work yet it
doesn't do anything can you click on
them but it looks ok all right cool
I got through everything in the live
chat so if I happen to miss your
question I'm really sorry I try to get
through everything but if I did miss
your question just put it in the
comments to this video or send me a
message on some social media thing and
I'll shred you back to you soon as I can
see I think that's it yeah I'll be back
tomorrow sometime around 2 p.m.
and until then have a great day
you